- Are you fucking crazy?
(crew laughing)
Do you know how bad your
traditional TV ad is
no matter how awesome you are?
(screaming)
You got your perspective.
(upbeat tech music)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat tech music)
I would run Facebook and LinkedIn ads
and make contextual creative
to the data that shows me
who the historic customers
you tend to get are,
and I would run the ads
against those demographics
and psychographics,
and I would make 43 different pieces
of video starring you
or somebody else that
went to bring them value
so that we built awareness.
- [Interviewer] So those
ads would not look like
my traditional TV ads?
- Are you fucking crazy?
(interviewer laughing)
- Do you know how bad
your traditional TV ad is
no matter how awesome you are?
- [Interviewer] How do you
stay ahead of that curve?
- By building a brand Digger.
Digger, the only way you...
If that gets to the scale that it could.
Listen to the words.
In 15 years, the only
thing that's left is brand.
They have to say,
"Alexa, can you get me Digger."
Because if they say, "Give me a personal
"Give me a lawyer, give me a whatever --
"A trainer, a milkshake, a whatever,"
they're going to have.
And that is going to play out.
(upbeat tech music)
- [Interviewer] So I have
2000 bills to work with,
I'm on the radio every
second, I'm on the TV.
All the stuff--
- Yeah. If you--
- [Interviewer] All the
stuff you talk about.
How do I transition--?
- By taking 20-40% of
that money and putting it
100% into something like
Facebook against your core demo.
45-90 that still translates there.
And then by teaming up
with your team and others
to take 5% and start the
beginning of that next generation.
Which is not gonna -- You are
not gonna do well at first,
or maybe even at all
on Instagram at first,
but it's just starting
to build the awareness.
But I will promise you this,
Sir, and this is universal:
There is no radio and
billboard perfect execution
that trumps perfect Facebook execution
for who you're trying to reach.
Here's why:
Common sense.
That billboard is vanilla.
The fact that you can make
a reference to Jaylen Hearst
transferring to Oklahoma.
You could do all sorts of shit.
You could make 8,000
billboards that matter
to 8,000 different
psychographic and demographic.
Alabama's got a lot of
micro personalities.
Genders, races, age groups.
You're going to make a -- you know why?
The Andy Warhol Superbowl
commercial last year
that Burger King did missed the mark
because nobody under 40
fucking knew what the fuck
was going on.
(crew laughing)
When you sell vanilla.
Vanilla's a popular flavor,
but when you sell vanilla
you miss a lot of customers.
And what you're doing
is sheer penetration.
And you're no dummy.
Billboards can't work as well
as they did 10 years ago.
Every passenger's looking
down at their phone.
I'd rather them see your pretty face.
(upbeat tech music)
- [Interviewer] For people that are not,
I get the sense that attorney's are not
their customers.
If you're a corporate
attorney, your customer's not
fucking around on Facebook even.
What's another way to
gather and create community
of scale for sharing?
Like is Mighty Networks,
is that stuff you see that coming out?
- I think it's less about
putting them into a funnel
that's a technical infrastructure
and it's more about
taking the thought of
community, layering it up.
So for example, one
thing that I think people
are very naive of is how digital
is actually the gateway to real life.
So I think if you put out
great content on LinkedIn,
for example, which these customers are on,
and you're bringing value to them from
their perspective not yours,
and then the 19th post
you put in, or the 900th is,
"Hey, I'm actually gonna be
putting together a dinner,
"where we're gonna drink some good wine
"and just talk about
business, or this industry,
"or corporate law.
"And the first eight people to RSVP,
"I'll see you in a private
room in the restaurant."
I think what -- when you
want to get to the top,
the way to put them into a Facebook group
is to give them good wine in
a private room in a restaurant
that you use the digital
content to create the RSVP.
(upbeat tech music)
- [Interviewer] So how
much time do you spend,
because we've been going up
the funnel in trying to do that
with the more complex
ones, monetizing and going
down the funnel structure.
How much importance of time do you put on,
Is it a byproduct, you just do a lot
and you naturally learn from it?
Or you consciously focus
the things you are learning
as you are doing them?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] What's
the give and take? The--
- Fully that.
- [Interviewer] All day seconds.
- Well, I spend 100% of my time
on watching people react to
things, not to the actual thing.
- [Interviewer] You mean
not toward the output?
- 100%.
But I also, and what
DRock would tell you is
my copy skill -- I know what people want
because I'm listening first.
For all my talking, and all
my interrupting the question,
and all this, I'm listening at all times.
Thus, I have a better sense.
I just know what resonates
because I'm so --
And don't forget, and you know this,
this is now fucking 37 years of --
This is talent.
I've had to come to realize,
I'm like, "Oh right."
In business, in entrepreneurship
and communication,
no different than in
singing and in sports,
there is natural talent.
The reason I set up the
conversation around lemonade
and baseball cards, I've
been doing this for so long.
It's why I was such an atrocious student.
It was so black and white to me
that I couldn't even pander
to societal norms of the 80's,
to even appease my poor
mother who would punish me
so bad every report card,
because I wanted that every
second in the classroom
to figure out why did they
laugh when I disrupted that?
Why is everybody wearing those sneak --
I mean, I literally just said
something that I've never,
I know DRock's never heard of this.
I used to sit in class
and fundamentally analyze
everything people wore.
Without even knowing why I was doing that.
And so, that's it.
- [Interviewer] But then
how much of the time is
you spend within audience building,
versus thinking about
how to monetize it --
- I spend no --
- [Interviewer] Or reactive to
understanding the hook?
- I'm a little but unusual,
and I think you know this.
I have a separate business
that doesn't monetize
my audience, thus I spend no time.
My great secret compared to
all the other personalities,
is none of the important finances come.
- [Interviewer] What's the output?
How much time do you spend
thinking about the monetization--
- Zero.
Because the framework's
already been created.
- [Interviewer] The audience is there.
But then you think about it
in different contexts, though.
- I just know there's some trickle down,
but zero thought into it.
I don't know, you know, it's
just not the way I think.
I build other businesses to
make sure I don't have to rely
on any conversion from it.
You can ask DRock, when we sell
a t-shirt for fun to learn,
like I'll do on my text
messaging platform,
or if it's those sneakers, or the wine,
I weirdly like better
when it doesn't do well.
- [Interviewer] But it
does monetize the ideas,
unconscious for you, but
you have people in place
to actually translate it.
- Yes, but again, the economics
are so minute in comparison.
Yes.
But really, that fuckin matters.
That changes the entire intent paradigm.
- I'm always trying to
figure out a good formula
of when to engage and when not to.
Sometimes it's nice when
a client engages for us,
you know, if it's a bad review --
- [Gary] It's a great question, yeah.
- But I haven't quite
figured out a good formula --
- There is no formula.
I actually think you've got
it down, cause I do the same.
I just think it comes down
to timing and serendipity.
Sometimes you just got 15
minutes, and you know you're --
sometimes, when there's a lot
of things going bad around me,
I've got some fires, I've got some issues,
my grandma passed away this last summer.
You know, life, right?
The Jets are 0-3, I'm on tilt, you know?
Sometimes I'm not just in the
mood to know I'm gonna have
to spend 15 minutes, maybe going
back and forth to try to --
right?
Other times, I'm bored, I'm feelin fresh,
I got eight minutes cause
something got canceled,
and I'm like, "I'm gonna get in there."
I wouldn't over judge yourself.
There is no proper answer.
I think it's predicated
on your current mindset
to be able to be the bigger person.
People lose cause they go into
a debate or a conversation,
but they're not emotionally balanced,
which allows them to get triggered,
which makes them overreact,
which changes the context
of the actual merit
of the conversation, which
fucks up the whole thing.
AKA America.
(upbeat techn music)
- Do you think you have
to get someone in-house,
cause you're never gonna go when you go,
"Oh, we're gonna spend $30,000
a month with this agency
"to help us with our
Facebook stuff," right?
- I think at a small scale,
in-house is a great way to go.
I do.
You can steal somebody.
My belief is that everybody
I'm looking at right now
should take the at-bat to try
to figure it out themselves
because it's that important.
That was the point I made
about balancing your checkbook.
To me, communications is oxygen.
No different than actually understanding
how to handle cash flow.
I really believe that.
I believe it's become
that singularly important.
I really believe that.
(upbeat tech music)